are the aliens real or not tell me bro i
don't know we're gonna find out though
you know the first time we ever hung out
this is after we did the podcast
yeah tell them we went out today i don't
think anybody knows about this they
might not
you tell me hey what are you doing for
dinner tonight after i do the pot and
i'm like well [ __ ] huh i don't have any
plans on my l.a he goes well come to
dinner with me at the what is it the
all-you-can-eat brazilian restaurant
what's it called in the shop vogua to
chow
he goes come the folk of the chow and
the when you type it i don't even know
what food we're eating
it right it's like okay it's a brazilian
restaurant so we go and you're like
we're gonna come with this with bob i go
okay cool and we go with bob lazar this
is the the guy who is was working on the
ufc and i explained to you who he was
because i wanted you to get a read on
yeah because i wanted you to decide
whether or not you thought it was
[ __ ] this is a guy that was
allegedly according to him he back
engineered
alien spacecraft at area s4
there's a guy who worked for lockheed
martin
and he
claims that he worked on these ufos and
we all went out to dinner
and we're sitting there and and
andrew and i are cutting meat and eating
and just talking i got my green light on
they keep coming around this guy joe's
like put the [ __ ] red light on you
had enough steak whatever the [ __ ] it is
i don't know the rules are poker yeah
yeah you get a green card it's the best
[ __ ] place ever if you love meat you
have a green card on one side and it's
red on the other side and so when you
want to keep that food rolling you keep
that green up but andrew's it's like
[ __ ] sick
he's taking chicken legs i go you got to
flip it over if you got to tap out
give you a break yeah so you flip it
over it's a good system so we're sitting
there eating and bob lazar is detailing
to us [ __ ] that he couldn't even talk
about on the podcast wow
and explaining like what what they were
trying begrudgingly by the way begrudge
and that's what kind of convinced me he
was like
i don't care to argue about this or
debate about this like if if you don't
believe me it's fine i don't need to be
here because i don't even care yeah
remember he kept saying that yeah and
then he was like this is what i
experienced and i care a little bit you
dedicate your whole life to this no he
didn't dedicate his life like he he was
an engineer he was only there for a
short period of time and he here's the
word gets wild wanna hear the whole
story yeah he
had top secret clearance because he has
to work on these crafts allegedly
according to him but because of that
they had to tap into his phones they had
to monitor all of his discussions like
if he's selling information to the
russians
okay so during that time period his wife
is having an affair
and they
they kill his top secret clearance and
suspend him during this time period and
with no explanation because they think
he'll be emotionally unsafe unstable and
you can't have a guy like that working
on [ __ ] ufos so they don't tell him
though they don't tell him his wife is
cheating on him so he's trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] is going on and he
brings friends out into the mountains to
view the launches of these ufos because
they're on a very specific schedule and
he knows the schedule so he takes these
people out deep into the nevada desert
which is now the area though he took
people to you can't even go there
anymore it's now off limits but at the
time you can go there and he was
watching with his friends they were
filming these [ __ ] things flying
around in like these preposterous ways
that no airplane can fly did you see any
of the videos i've seen it but you don't
know what you're looking at yeah like
you're looking at lights like it could
be anything that was the elon thing yeah
yeah elon said some [ __ ] like why don't
they have uh you know better camera
footage available yeah but they do he's
not totally correct the fleer footage
that they have from the david fravor the
commander david favor had one of the
most impactful ufo video encounters that
that's ever happened it was off the
coast of san diego and they they
found this thing that moved from 50 000
feet above sea level to 50 in less than
a second
they don't know what it is they have no
idea what it was but it was actively
monitoring them because it blocked all
of their tracking devices which is
technically an act of war and then
just [ __ ]
just took off gone and went back to
their cat point which is the place where
they had like they had like a designated
spot where they're supposed to meet up
during this mission because what they're
doing with this mission is there's a
training mission and they had to
dedicate and that [ __ ] ufo went to
that spot it's like i know where you're
going [ __ ]
and it took off again and gone and then
when they relayed this to the nimitz
he was explaining how the people that
were working there were like we see
these things like every couple weeks we
have no idea what the [ __ ] it is we
don't know so you're 100 convinced ufos
i'm not because it could be a drone that
they don't tell those people about it
could be something that the government's
working on um
most likely us see the thing about
communism is like it
like the way they do it over there is
like slash communism capitalism
maybe that works but a lot of what they
do is they steal they steal a lot of
intellectual property from the united
states it's one of the problems there's
not a problem with the united states
stealing intellectual property from
china as far as i know it doesn't make
the news but they banned huawei the
reason why they banned huawei's the cell
phone company right the company that
makes they make modems as well they make
many things but they found like enough
of an indication that they were
suspicious there's some back doors in
order to get data so if you're using
like huawei devices and you have
something super secure network that's
developing nuclear weapons or whatever
the [ __ ] you're doing they would get all
that data
and there's so there's like hey
you chill the [ __ ] out
you know we're in this weird time where
we're only like a decade or so away from
nothing being a secret ever what do you
mean there will be no more secrets
you'll be able to read minds
you're coming to a place where language
is probably going to be universal and
you're going to be able to communicate
with people that are nowhere near you
using the power of your thought this is
the neural link this is many of these
technologies they're developing if
you've got to think about where it's
going to go that's where it's going to
go that's one guy i talked to he said
that's the end point of ai that's where
it's all headed we're all in one
consciousness well it might be you gave
me a broken glass you [ __ ] suckers
i almost caught myself i would have died
wow wow if you um
please the russians please it was still
mine
it's no big deal
you drink out of this end i drink out of
that end yeah right this part
um what were we just talking about
the russians group consciousness
unconsciousness and singularity
what they're looking for
don't worry about all that
you're half of it missed it's a problem
bro
it's just water and your fingers and
[Music]
yeah you know i want to state for the
record that most of this podcast is
nonsense yeah uh i would say 100 that's
100 we like to be safe and just go
hundred percent that's all comedy yeah i
um
if asked i stand by none of my claims no
we're this is all scripted this is a
scripted podcast and this is for you
it's a parody exactly
okay but the with the five dudes drunk
with the ufo [ __ ] right
four
they're out there they're out there bro
say you believe it no the thing is i
don't believe it because i i don't know
for sure but if i had a guess i would
have to say most likely they're out
there because there's not enough options
like if you had to think that this is
the most unique circumstance ever in the
history of the universe
the problem with that is the universe is
too big yeah so it's so big that
everything that's ever existed including
everything that's ever happened on earth
in the exact same order has happened an
infinite number of times but you have to
understand what infinity means it's too
big for anybody to understand
so are there aliens of course there's
not just aliens out there you're out
there you're you're not just out there
once you're out there
an impossible number of times and you're
doing life all kinds of different ways
the number of people that live exactly
the same as you have with every pause
every mistake every success all of it is
exactly the same it's infinite that's
how big the universe is and there's also
one that's the opposite yes failures
disgrace everything falling apart murder
suicide all of it
probably every single iteration of human
beings vegan you out there joe
and that [ __ ] that's where you
cross the line
yeah i just wonder man
if you watch the moose
stomp a person at death you think you'd
eat that moose
i tell i'll suck the moose's dick and
i'm good bro i don't know what you don't
understand about me i'm an apex predator
this mouth
mouth is a predator dog
take some mushrooms out guys
you need something like a massage or
something
something's therapeutic
like yoga class i don't know what to
tell you bro it's this married life joe
this is married life guys that clip was
brought to you by blue chew best boners
in the business same active ingredients
as cialis or viagra but this is the true
the only one we rock with get yours for
free at bluetooth.com promo code andrew
all you gotta do is pay five dollars
shipping